[Music]
another gorgeous day today temperatures
warmed up today too
since the past few days where we had
that 59 degree high
on monday and that was it now we're back
to 75 that puts us right near average
49 for the overnight low so even the
overnight temperatures also
have improved and will slowly warm up as
we get
to halloween weekend 77 centi hills
right now
summerlin you're at 73 74 for aliante
the east side
78 sunrise mountain how about henderson
currently 74 for you green valley
whitney ranch at 76. rhodes ranch
mountains edge
both in the mid 70s right now and 74
currently
for seven hills outside the valley 79
for prump
77 sandy valley boulder city you're
checking in right now at 74 degrees
as we take a look across the lower 48
the reason i'm showing you this is
because you can see
it's slightly warmer across the west
coast now but still
very cold across the nation's midsection
from
denver all the way to kansas city up to
chicago 45
only in dallas the reason for that is
the jet stream
still dipping down here the low
providing plenty of
snow and even some moisture for wichita
and portions of the texas panhandle
while we're dry on the back side of this
this is the ridge now over us so let's
update you now on hurricane zeta yes we
are actually that's actually zeta
third hurricane to hit louisiana this
year there are now tornado watches in
effect as zeta has already made landfall
and it's still a category two
hurricane and it will eventually die out
as it heads over land here because it
doesn't have the warmer waters to feed
it
will become a tropical storm and
eventually a post-tropical low and
here's its impacts
all the way up to the jersey shore can
you believe it and then eventually the
carcass of that will head out
to sea so here's how it looks overnight
temperatures will be dropping to 53
degrees clear
and cool overnight winds will be light
or at least light breezes from the
northwest
your high for tomorrow warming up even
more 77 degrees
sunny but still comfortable i can't
complain about 77 right
winds light and variable so we'll have
those winds less than 10 throughout many
of our neighborhoods
and our normal 75 so we'll be slightly
above average for
this time of the year 75 for centennial
hills 76 mountains edge tomorrow
north las vegas you'll be at 76 and
we'll be at 75 for henderson 79 green
valley
and also areas like whitney ranch 75 for
prom along with boulder city 84 loughlin
tomorrow
for your thursday and here's how
halloween looks right back to 80 degrees
for halloween i think by the time we
go trick-or-treating we're looking more
like the mid to low 70s
and guess what not bad at all right we
hit election day
warmer than average back to the low 80s
but still not too bad
at all that is your most accurate
weather update here on 8 news now